my name is John Lewis I'm studio art
director at frontier and yeah focusing
on the planet coaster that's what i want
to show you today so yeah what we've got
here is it's the bill heading up to
alpha 2 so there's some wonderful things
in here and it's always improving so
what I want to show you some of the new
features there's lots of great
improvements on the power thing for
example that we had before in alpha 1
but I'm going to take you all through
the game as we have it so let's say that
this park is a this is a good part
because it's kind of fledgling park but
you can see that over here there's area
to move into unfortunately you consider
this path has nowhere to go okay I could
string out the top i really want to
create tunnel so i'm going to use this
to show you some of the unrivaled tools
thor for sculpting landscape so first of
all the ones that one thing i want
straight away is and when i'm going to
put a foundation down for this box i'm
going to flatten all the ground out
around here and that's going to just cut
through that tunnel for me not you can
write you can make brushes bigger and
smaller using keyboard shortcuts what a
what's lovely about all this is actually
it's a little bit like some packages
that you may have used which are brushes
you know we kind of looked at popular
painting packages and things so people
can feel that there's a definite time to
certain so I'm practicing so you're kind
of punch through that landscape it's
awesome and now I can run a little path
through there because the past we've
worked on a lot in this which is great
so we've made actually joining and stuff
are far easier we've also made it so you
can create really lovely parts which are
suddenly quite quite different from
before so on this side I might make it
more like a kind of country pop so I'm
going to use our more naked and more
naked part so you see it's kind of its
like the people will be walking in the
ground the Luthor before you couldn't
actually make proving pass quite like
this so that's new rep that you youtube
more right angles you can actually
create a fully so you can make you can
make coding pearls so
you can make it wobble all over the
place but and also the way that we did
it is that single i turning angle snap
on you can actually make in a really
good geometric shapes but what was
missing before was that you if you
wanted to elevate the path it would
always go in a straight line so you run
into that situation there but what I'm
going to do now is show a really
beautiful thing and so you've got these
great pop options so now I can put on
curved elevation and if I go up again
now I can actually make a gentle slope
which is curving so you can make these
really elegant looking plants and it's
not just slips that come down when I can
go over here and then go up again one
more and now it's a spiral staircase
going all the way up yeah so I can make
these really quite exciting elevated
pathways which are always look which
will keep that lovely curb you look the
absolute the fantastic link up with the
tools i think is is is how so I've
created this they should has shaped
through here but there's no there's no
clear and obvious reason for me to have
done that elevate this part so what I
might have done is I might be planning
show you so to take the terrain sores
I've just been showing there and I'm
going to build this the train up i'm
going to use a really a really fantastic
feature which is something that respects
the landscape that you've that you've
already in a building so let's take that
and whack the intensity up through the
roof and this will drag that up mate you
see instantly that's actually really
respecting the ground and all of the
path layout that you put down so that
remains true and solid and this is
slowly heading up towards the path above
you yeah so let's say that I wanted to
eventually get to the path and then my
idea is I want to build a plateau of
land out here and then try and trap your
plan so I can build my my little
foundation tool brush suddenly hey
presto and in within seconds we've kind
of got this I've created a section where
by I can go up here and then start
building out back again pedana
a lovely as for the spicket works as an
icebox there's a long way to go for the
loop but nonetheless it's an important
thing so there you go it's also
connecting and it's soon so it's
improving upon everything we had before
but offering such a huge amount of
potential but you just you know is it
you just didn't have this and are you
any won't have it I don't know how he
would get this i mean that's a really
beautiful lovely sweeping curb retiring
i might break halfway up there
eventually but it's it's a pretty cool
thing but what you can also do such as
let's say yum you're built than you
think actually i don't like that
everything is editable I mean the lovely
thing about planet about planet coaster
is everything and this is something you
never had before is I can go in and just
simply change the path textures to make
it feel movie oh it feels more natural
than it than it did before and I can do
that for the entire and set yeah it's
pretty awesome the commune's done
amazing things with the themes that
we've got in the game currently no
they've they've taken effect we took two
themes that we had and then created
between pirates between may using a
pirate theme and a and a super
contemporary white art actual theme
they've generated kind of people Swiss
dillards and then you know everything
from that too I believe the most recent
one I've seen which is awesome as a
complete model very large bonus size of
a park of the other an imperial star
destroyer from Star Wars so that was
skip that was that was breathtaking that
was a fantastic piece of work you know
the idea that they could then go in and
pretty much sculpt and paint a you know
jack who around the outside of its
pretty pretty intense I think so yeah
we've delivered a naught we just built
so much more on top of the advert kind
of creativity tools that you had before
but and it does all come back to keeping
them keeping your park entertaining for
for the guests but also i mean the great
thing about something like this the
train towards were given is actually you
can make your park occupy that ever
smaller smaller space lots of real world
designer to feed box you try and make
the space is very optimal so you need to
see around here it's it's very dense you
know the whole point of it is dense so
that's great one respect to your people
then get tired so quickly but another
way if I can if I can sculpt the land
you know as you're seeing a lot of new
thing box you know that where they're
doing far more land landscaping you know
quite extreme landscape in the case of
sleep and take you Disney forgives you
could see Disney can never stay right I
mean when you look at what they're doing
they're doing some amazing earthworks to
build that parks so the game has always
been built on the idea of following the
individual if not all caring about
individual so each one of these people
I'm not tracking her so I can kind of
walk along with her but what we've
really gone have gone big with the with
the camera option so i can i can i can
see what it's like being aura aurora and
look around my Park get first kind of
feature I view of the park she only got
a ride and again that Q my fullest on us
that's great she's which is earning
money but if I go over to this section
this is a great way of seeing how
following people through the park not
only tells you how pretty your Park is
it also you can see with this guy here
it tells you that your simulation is
actually well really well adjusted and
you can see that so there's a hat there
lots of merchandise hat you can see that
your hat shop here is actually doing
really quite well because I'm going to
see so many to get pirate hat I can see
the baseball hats from them panic
coasters theme so I'm getting a sense of
how the simulation is supporting the
game and that's all without me checking
a graph or anything else everything you
see in here I mean this is a very
modern-looking park it uses the planet
coaster style it's not mix anything but
everything you see is is a sum of its
parts but so let's say I really love
that building there and in mind you in
my new area up there I wanted to put
that in over I want to use that I can
keep the cave that section and bring it
over here and actually expand the park
however I once it yeah so I could drop
that down anyway
but no knee is that so that building in
itself is the sum of lots of individual
parts so i can go in here and pick
section i can change it so all this all
this area around here is open to editing
it's not a pre-baked building i can get
rid of that pretty easily change it just
as quickly we're going to here and pick
maybe that one instead snap it in there
if I don't want sir so that's kind of
nice actually I think it's better than
it was before don't bit cooler bo so
everything can be changed everything is
is entirely open to customization for
the player there is there is if you like
nothing set in stone up clearly you can
if you like a building or if you like
something that someone else is built
eventually you'll be able to share a
blueprint your week just grab that loop
because if you're a manager you don't
necessarily want to always create but
the fantastic thing is that if you
happen to like you know this this
entrance here you could take what I've
what I've made with the entrance there
bring it into your own Park and then
start the leaking stuff and and change
it to being whatever you want it to be
so you might actually want it so that
you know that you only have blue
sections there and then do something
completely different with the
decorations you might want to take into
a very dark place it should just be
wrong so alpha 2 but this is heading
towards is out on the 24 and it builds
in a way that I think it builds in such
a way that you can make anything really
that your imagination either at this
stage can come a thing called the Train
tools you won't you just simply won't
find better I don't think I may I can I
can handle heart say that because
there's so much freedom you know we're
kind of built mount rushmore we've built
crazy 400 foot high trees they're all in
the bills and we've built but more
important we were built actually really
quite exciting interesting parts which
feel real I mean you can't you won't get
this from anything else out there and
you won't be able to I don't get
the sheer level of customization alpha
to wear with all the fantastic tools for
terrain building that's all out on may
24 the actual game app and the year
without doubt it's the SD pc game this
year